a Microsoft without xbox that's a future
Bill Gates will support if the company
ever decides to spin off the Xbox
division I'm mark Walton and this is a
game spot news update speaking to Fox
Business Network reports at liz claman
Gates said that if Microsoft CEO Satya
Nadella wanted to spin off the Xbox
business unit he would absolutely
support it Microsoft has never said it
has any plans to sell off its Xbox
business unit but major shareholders
including Microsoft co-founder paul
allen's investment group have urged the
company to spin off the game unit and
instead focus on corporate customers
however gates doesn't think the Xbox
business is likely to transition to a
standalone company because it is tied to
Microsoft's long-term strategy gates
also pointed out that Microsoft is
beginning to bring pc gaming and console
gaming a lot closer together with the
arrival of the xbox one spinning off a
business unit is a way for companies to
streamline their business and it doesn't
necessarily mean selling to another firm
altogether one example of such a move
came in 2011 when travel site expedia
announced that it was splitting into two
companies Xbox co-creator ed fry said
last month that Microsoft will be
foolish to sell off the Xbox Bram it's
the biggest most successful brand near
created in the last 15 years they should
learn from the success of Xbox and
create more things like it not sell it
off think Xbox would be better off
without its Microsoft overlords or would
like something wise to hold on to one of
its biggest brands let us know in the
comments below and for all your gaming
news keep it going spot